ex machina stars domhnall gleeson and
Oscar Isaac and is the story of a guy
who works at some sort of computer
organization they don't quite make it
entirely clear it's sort of like today's
Google and the guy who created this
search engine has also created something
else the very first ever a I and he asks
don't listen to come and try to test
this system out and as you may expect he
grows a little too attached to this
robot and that's where the problems
start I'm a huge fan of science fiction
and especially cerebral science fiction
the kind that accesses your brain that
makes you think that gives you
thought-provoking ideas and gratefully
ex machina is filled with all of these
traits one of the best parts of this
movie is the fact that it really does
try to get into the human psyche looking
at how we operate through our search
engine results being able to figure out
what kind of person we are just based on
things that we type into our computer
and the creator of that search engine
played by Oscar Isaac able to figure out
who we are as people based off things we
type as well as our relationship with
technology and those are by far my
favorite aspects of this movie it's also
a very well shot movie while slowly
paced and a little bit snail like at
times in regards to how fast it moves I
was always interested in where the film
was going and my favorite performance in
this movie is definitely Oscar Isaac he
had a lot of really cool character
traits about him he was kind of a drunk
but he liked to work out but he was also
this extremely smart guy who was able to
create the first AI so he was really a
fascinating character and Alicia
vikander she did a really good job as
the AI herself there were a lot of great
nuances that she added to her
performance it wasn't just the cliched
like robot thing where you go like this
and look around like there were actually
some things you could see behind those
robotic eyes strangely though I wasn't a
big fan of domhnall gleeson performance
in this movie even though I really liked
him in Frank and Calvary and Harry
Potter films I've liked him in the past
but I felt that he didn't really give
that much to his character here I didn't
really find his character very
interesting and some of that convening
the script and the writing I just didn't
really latch onto his character which
kind of sucks because he's the main
character of the movie he also makes
certain character choices that I did not
understand at all and his attachment
that develops I felt was sort of cliched
and I didn't really feel made sense for
who he was as a person especially things
that he does
towards the latter half of the film that
I won't spoil it just didn't really make
sense and it felt kind of like the
script was making him do things that he
wouldn't do as a person and in all
honesty the way the film ended I found
very predictable I could see that coming
from the very beginning and it didn't
surprise me and one choice made by a
helicopter pilot I just can't really
understand it's a small thing but it's
actually not a small thing so it kind of
just bugged me a little bit that's a
smaller thing that I'm not really
detracting from the movie just during
the movie I was like why did he just
accept that like if you've seen the
movie you know exactly what I'm talking
about probably all in all guys though I
would recommend seeing this movie I do
think people are blowing it a little out
of proportion may be over rating it just
a little bit calling it like the next
Kubrick and stuff I don't think it's
that good but I do think it's a good
movie and my voice is actually starting
to go away so I'm gonna give this movie
a B sorry guys I'm getting over a cold
right now I'm trying to get through
these videos thank you so much as always
for watching and I do want to quickly
let you know that my promotion with
crunchyroll is still going on that's one
of the reasons I'm wearing an anime
shirt as well as the fact that ghost in
the shell' is an AI right now if you go
to crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman
you can get 30 days of this anime
streaming service absolutely free my
gift to you for being awesome you guys
know I'm a huge fan of anime huge fan of
robots these are all things you can find
on crunchyroll comm and they have a lot
of new shows coming up very soon as well
that are being added including Naruto
one piece and Sailor Moon crystal I'm
excited to check some of those out so if
you go to crunchyroll.com slash chris
stuckman you can get 30 days for free on
me my gift to you guys I am trying to do
promotions that I can actually give you
guys something it's cool for me to be
able to talk to some of these companies
and work things out on my videos but I'm
always looking for ways to give my
viewers something and my voice is
completely going away at this point so
please if you would like to have that
service for free for 30-days visit the
link in the description below guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes